countries that most Americans do not go
into like Afghanistan and so assuming he
returned safely from his journey we
should have an excellent book in October
thanks for talking to us thank you in
evolution Pulitzer prize-winning author
Edward Larson explores the history of
the scientific theory from pre Darwinian
debates on the origin of life to the
discovery of the double helix by James D
Watson the sock from warwick bookstore
in la jolla california is an hour 15
minutes this evening we have Warwick's
is pleased to welcome edward jones
larson I'm sorry Edward Larson is here
tonight to talk about his book evolution
the remarkable history of a scientific
theory in two thousand the modern
library launched its Chronicle series
and the series is a small format
hardcover volumes that cover the world's
feature the world's great historians
writing brief histories about ideas and
events that have shaped our modern world
with over forty titles it has proved to
be a superb and popular series evolution
the remarkable history of a scientific
theory by tonight's guest is certainly a
worthy and exciting addition to the
modern library chronicles Edward Larson
currently is the talmage professor of
law and the Russell professor of history
at the University of Georgia as an
author miss dr. Larson has been very
prolific and proclaimed he has authored
05 books and over 60 published articles
dr. Lawson has demonstrated repeatedly a
gift for showing the force of ideas in
shaping and defining the world in which
we live his 1997 book summer for the
gods was a Pulitzer Prize winner and he
is urn was the first sitting law
professor to be awarded a pod surprise
in history in addition his articles have
appeared in dozens of journals including
The Wall Street Journal
atlantic monthly nature and the
Scientific American in his new book
evolution the remarkable history of a
scientific theory dr. Larson follows the
path of evolutions evolution from its
origins in the late 18th century geology
through Charles Darwin and Alfred wall
Wallace and the 20th century emergence
of neo-darwinism synthesis he traces and
offers insightful so she earns on such
critical topics as the Scopes trial
science education and eugenics dr.
Larson provides a thoroughly compelling
and readable history of one of the most
popular and consequential scientific
principles of our time please join me in
welcoming dr. Edward Larsen thank you
for that very kind invitation welcome
and invitation to be here that you gave
me now a couple people came in late and
there are a couple seats over there if
you'd want to sit on that side rather
than have to be sort of in the back
you're welcome to go across well again
thank you all for coming out here after
how beautiful beautiful it was today
with the sun out in the middle of the
June gloom I was so happy that it
clouded up because I was afraid nobody
would come after how the weather looked
began to look so thank you for coming
thank you for inviting me to this
wonderful classic bookstore in the heart
of lovely La Jolla near spectacular San
Diego I can't think of a better place to
visit on a book tour now tonight what I
thought I'd do was give somewhat of a
modified reading for my book let me
explain why what I've written here is a
narrative history of a scientific theory
that is I've tried to take a scientific
theory and follow its history and put
together like a story like it or not the
theory of evolution is one of the grand
ideas of our day
like liberty or democracy it's an idea
with force now this particular idea the
theory of evolution is rooted in science
but that science itself is rooted in
society in our culture and in turn the
scientific theory of evolution has
influenced and helped shape our society
and culture over that's two hundred year
history this book narrates the evolution
is or the evolution of this theory in
social context as such it includes a
whole variety of major episodes stories
within the story that bring the history
of the theory evolution alive stories
some of which we all know some of which
are fairly famous some of which aren't
is well known as they should be great
stories in the history of ideas like
Darwin's voyage of the bagel which was a
big part of him coming up with the idea
deciding that species evolved rather
than were created or eugene de blaas his
discovery of java man to the can through
poss tremendous story in the history of
paleontology a gripping story really the
work in genetics with the pea plants of
a Mendel story there or Thomas Hunt
Morgan with the fruit flies or Hugo
diverse with the with the evening
primrose these are stories and I try to
tell those threes or more recently
Watson and Crick's discovery of double
helix which is crucial to modern
evolutionary thought how the double
helix works how DNA works but in
addition to having these episodes that
appear throughout the book also follows
some grand themes that reappear in
different ages and different sort of
manifestations of the history of theory
of evolution because it didn't spring
full-blown in the idea of the mind of
Darwin indeed it was around well before
Darwin Lamarck had worked out the idea
for example before fifty years before
the idea of evolution is changed a lot
over these two hundred years but there's
certain grand themes that that reappear
in the narrative things like the role of
fossils in the history of the theory of
evolution or changes in the social
status of science from being sort of a
just another intellectual force to a
dominant intellectual force and the
theory of evolution sort of rose with it
or materialism versus theism which runs
through it continues to run through the
debates over evolution so there are lots
of different themes at some readings
I've read selected episodes and I've
taken my book and gone from episode to
episode and that's one way but to keep
myself from being bored I've also other
times tried to follow a theme throughout
and then that's when I've used a
modified reading tonight I decided to
take that approach and follow a theme
through the book the theme I chose that
pic was the impact of this particular
scientific theory on our cultural view
of the human soul now there is where
evolution really hits the road and I
thought since I was in San Diego where
this issue is is the issue of evolution
is is a major issue because you've got
the University of California San Diego a
tremendous Center for evolutionary
research just down the road in fact you
of course you can see it when you step
out the building and look sort of around
the corner you've also got Center for
creation science located right here in
the San Diego area so you sort of got
these issues and there's no place this
theme resonates any better than than the
theme of the impact of the scientific
theory of evolution on the cultural view
of the human soul and doing it here in
San Diego so I thought I'd take that
approach if you didn't mind now to do
that what i've done is i've picked
passages out of the book and woven them
together with a little connecting
material but mostly what i'll be doing
is I'll reading parts from the book but
rather than read it right out of the
book I went back to where i had the
chapters all on my computer and pulled
out the passages and did the weaving
together so if you bear with me out i'll
try that approach and yeah and we'll go
that way
in 1859 within a week of receiving a
pre-publication copy of his former
students bold new book on the origin of
species the great 19th century Cambridge
University geologist Adam Sedgwick rope
to Charles Darwin quote I have read your
book with more pain than pleasure tis
the crown and glory of organic science
that it does through final cause link
material to moral you have ignored this
link and if I do not mistake your
meaning you have done your best in one
or two pregnant cases to break it
weren't possible which thank God it is
not to break it humanity in my mind
would suffer a damage that might
brutalize it now Adam Sedgwick perhaps
the most famous geologist in the world
at that time he had been Darwin's
teacher and tag Darwin had gone on a
field trip with him when he was a
student at at Cambridge and he sent Adam
Sedgwick a copy of his book now Adam
Sedgwick was also a very devout
Christian now not an arrow necessarily
fundamentalist Christian but he was a
very sincere Christian he read this book
as it says with more more pain than
pleasure the book hadn't yet even come
out the public hadn't got says what got
this book and read it on literally and
you know the Origin species one of the
great you know wonderful read read it
almost immediately and sent this letter
back even before the book had been
published more pain than pleasures his
own students book and then he points out
after having read it it's a crown and
glory of organic science that organic
science biology links material material
us material things with moral with
ethics with morality with the soul with
the eternal with a supernatural material
with the supernatural the natural with
the natural and he's claiming that
you've ignored it and if I don't mistake
your meeting you've done your best in
one or two pregnant pregnant cases to
break it
possible and I he says I thank God it's
not possible you can't succeed at this
but if it were humanity in my mind would
suffer damage that might brutalize it
brute make it a brute Adam Cedric was
always very careful with his words so
there's a response even before the book
came out so you know if he's getting
that from his former teacher and friend
before the where the booking comes out
we're in for it we're in for a wild ride
in Victorian England when they think
about how this is going to affect the
soul well origin the species of course
was the book that Darwin used to launch
publicly his theory of evolution by
natural selection itself a product of
over two decades of painstaking largely
private research which in turn followed
in the wake of Darwin's famous four and
a half year around-the-world voyage as a
young naturalist aboard the british
survey ship hms beagle it was during
that voyage that Darwin first took
seriously the idea that current plant
and animal species may have evolved from
pre-existing species rather than been
specially created by God as an idea
evolution was as old as science itself
but had never gained widespread
acceptance among scientists at least
until Darwin's day now writing to Darwin
after he received his advance copy of
Origin of Species Harvard University
botanist ASA gray the man who introduced
Darwin's ideas to America one of the
very few people one of the fork
scientists that Darwin had discussed his
theory of evolution before he made it
public he also sent ASA gray a
pre-publication copy and ASA gray wrote
back a letter somewhat different than
Sedgwick's but but that also expressed
concerns about the books theological
implications Darwin replied to gray in a
in a long interesting letter I had no
intention to write a theistic alee but I
own that I cannot see as plainly as
others do evidence of design and
beneficence on all sides of us there
seems to be too much misery in the world
I cannot persuade myself that Abba
nificent and omnipotent God would have
design Utley created the ick Demonia
with the express intention that their
feed of their feeding within the living
bodies of caterpillars or that the cat
should play with the mouse before
killing it eluding going on in the
letter alluding to William Paley's an
analogy between a crafted watch in the
human eye which was the Anglican
theologians famous proof of an
intelligent designer behind organic
creation behind us Darwin then added in
his letter to gray not believing this I
see no necessity of the belief that the
I was expressly designed even human
nature and mental ability might result
from natural processes he concluded in
his letter to gray the sequence in
Darwin's letter to gray is telling it
quickly passed from observations which
seemed bad in nature such as cruel
animal behavior that cat playing with
the mouse which most people hesitate to
blame on God then it jumps this letter
to their implications for what seemed
good in nature such as the human eye
which Victorians typically often
credited to God and then the letter
jumps and moves on to ponder the origin
of what seemed the best of all human
morality and mentality which
victorian-era natural theologians
typically hailed as the ultimate gift
and proof of the divine supernatural in
origin of species Darwin avoided making
comments about human evolution he never
mentions human evolution in the book
origin of species and he did so for a
reason he feared that such comments
would prejudice readers against his
general theory but in his private notes
in his private essays that he wrote to
himself to persuade himself and to work
out the ID in his own mind and in the
letters to friends if you go back
through these all the way back to the
late 1830s
50 20 years before Origin species is
published you'll see his long-standing
fascination with precisely this issue
the issue is did humans evolved that's
the one thing i found out most
interesting when i was working on on the
book most of the people involved with
the theory of evolution even if they
never wrote about humans that's the
issue that most interested them even if
they were working with fruit flies they
were really interested in humans and
that was the same way with Charles
Darwin even though it never comes up in
Origin species indeed in darwin's
earliest private notebooks on evolution
those notebooks are peppered with
comparisons between the strikingly
primitive people of Terra de fuego whom
he met on his Beagle voyage and pampered
primates in the London Zoo Darwin wrote
in 1838 over 20 years before Origin
species 1838 he wrote in his notebook
quote what man visit orangutang in
domestication here expressed expressive
wines see it's intelligent then let man
dare to boast of his proud preeminence
here he inserted a phrase quote not
understanding language of the wagons
puts them on a par with monkeys in a
later entry Darwin demanded compared the
fillet Guillen and a Reagan tang and
dare say different so great now Darwin
frequently speculated about animal
origins of human traits such as when he
wrote in 1839 again 20 years before
Origin species wrote in his private
notebook quote one tendency to kiss and
almost to bite that which one sexually
loves is probably due to our distant
ancestors have been like dogs to [ __ ]
this was about the time he got married
by the way any remained happily married
very happily married to one woman for
his entire life as for the vaunted mind
of man Darwin concluded quote it is no
more perfect than instincts of animals
human thought itself like animal
instincts he
attributed to brain structure chiding
himself quote oh you materialist right
in his notebook on the side oh you
materialist for thinking so continually
he probed the perceived boundary
questions another place in his notebooks
does a [ __ ] bra blush I am almost
sure that Freudians did he asked himself
at one point early on animals I think
should not do this while Darwin avoided
commenting publicly on human evolution
his most visible scientific supporter
the well-connected British comparative
anatomist th Huxley you know Darwin's
bulldog he didn't have the same
reticence he took up the cause of human
evolution immediately and made it his
own in 1863 barely three years after
Darwin's Origin of Species appeared
Huxley packaged the pieces of his
various arguments his public lectures
that he already given on human evolution
into a single popular book aim for the
British popular market called evidence
as demands place in nature ducks Lee
Huxley concluded in this book whatever
system of organs be studied the
structural differences that separate man
from the gorilla and the chimpanzee are
not so great as those which separate the
gorilla from the lower Apes the most
vexing question raised by Darwinism
concerns the not the origin of the body
structure but the origins of human
mental and moral attributes particularly
altruistic behavior or sacrificial love
could these distinguishing human
characteristics have evolved by a
naturalistic processes Victorian
evolution asks or did God implant them
in an evolved human body could a selfish
struggle for survival process produced
self sacrificing humans now
traditionally Christian theologians had
attributed these attributes to an
indwelling soul maybe not the bad things
people do but but altruistic behavior
that's if anything else is from a human
so the existence of this human soul they
posited lifted humans above animals
scientists generally segregated humans
from other animals on this basis as well
go all the way back to Aristotle's
theory of the rational soul which is
found only in humans through the
Cartesian dualism splitting physical
manner from human and divine soul so one
thing on the other side of the great
Cartesian dualism animals are all on the
one side the human soul and the divine
and the divine soul that's on the other
side or you can go through George Cuvier
early 19th century French great French
naturalist who had divided humans and
primates in two separate taxonomic
orders now Huxley in man's place in
nature lumped humans in the same order
with other primates and boldly ask quote
this is from his book is the
philanthropist or the saint to give up
his endeavors to lead a noble life
because the simplest studies of man
human nature reveals at its foundations
all the selfish passions and fierce
appetites of the meara's quadruped head
is mother love vile because a hen shows
or fidelity base because dogs possess it
these were the new questions of the
Victorian age of Charles Darwin well
after steering clear of the intense
public debate over human evolution for
over a decade in 1871 Darwin finally
broke his public silence we know he's
already been talking about in his
letters in his private notebooks but
he'd remained publicly silent on the
issue but he broke that silence with the
publication of a new book two-volume
book in 1871 his other one of his other
really classic books called the descent
of man he wrote the sole object of this
work is to consider firstly weather man
like every other species is descended
from some pre-existing form secondly the
manner of his development and thirdly
the value of the differences between the
so-called races of man in this book
Darwin raised the key issues that would
thereafter occupy researchers in the
field to this very day Darwin's basic
case for human evolution consists of two
parts
first he presented the by then
well-known evidence for the evolution of
the human body in atomic in an atomic
structure embryonic and embryonic
development people resemble other
animals he noted and the persistence of
monkey like rudimentary features well
such as a tail bone reinforced the
conclusion the human body evolved from
lower forms relying primarily on
structural similarities Darwin traced
human ancestry from quote the most
ancient Fran janitor's in the vertebrate
kingdom through ancient fishes and
amphibians and early marsupialis to the
new the new world monkey and old world
monkeys and from the latter at a remote
period to man the Wonder and glory of
the universe unquote that's from his
descent of man the body's evolution and
that's what he's talking about in that
part of the book the body's evolution
even if accepted did not settle the
matter in any conclusive way because
many believe that humans by this time
that humans stood apart from animals due
to their minds and their emotions not
their bodies Darwin that's extended his
naturalistic analysis to include those
mental and moral attributes that
supposedly uplift humanity such as
higher reasoning self-consciousness
religious devotion and the ability to
love the mental powers and moral
feelings of humor humans differed in
degree rather than in kind from those of
other animals he asserted with a
progressive gradient linking the lowest
beasts to the highest humans Darwin
highlighted the human-like qualities of
higher animals particularly pet dogs and
wild primates and the animal like
qualities of the lowest is he called
them the lowest savages quote can we
feel sure that an old dog with an
excellent memory never reflects on his
past pleasures in the chase and this be
a form of self-consciousness he wrote in
a typical passage another passage on the
other hand how can the hard-working wife
of a degraded Australian Savage reflect
on the nature of his of her own
existence !
similarly Darwin doubted whether wagons
felt religious devotion yet saw quotes
some distinct approach to this state of
mind in the deep love of a dog for his
master Darwin attributed the evolution
of even the most ennobling human traits
to the same gradual naturalistic
survival of the fittest processes that
he had envisioned is producing all
living things here was his theory of
evolution by natural selection applied
to human nature long ago in Africa he
suggested some anthropol apes descended
from the trees started walking erect in
open spaces began using their hands to
hold or to hunt and develop their brains
all in incremental steps that helped to
preserve the individual or its group as
an Origin of Species the variations
themselves were either inborn or
acquired with beneficial ones propagated
through natural selection Darwin
envisioned the winnowing process at work
among individuals nationalities races
and civilizations with plucky Englishmen
and their American offspring advancing
to the fore yet for all the power that
Darwin attributed to natural selection
and molding humanity and guiding its
advance he saw the process as incapable
of generating gender and external racial
differences for these Darwin resorted to
and elaborated on the secondary process
of sexual selection that he had
introduced in origin of the species to
account for the evolution of male mating
traits such as the Peacocks tail people
differ in what they find attractive
inmates Darwin explained Africans prefer
dark skin and depressed noses while
Europeans favored light skin and
straight nose as he asserted quote while
in Java a yellow not a white girl is
considered a beauty within each race
Darwin speculated sexual selection
propagates and exaggerates favorite
external characteristics as the most
attractive males mate mates are chosen
first and have the most children for
instance he's
gested that Hottentot women have large
bottoms because tribesmen desire mates
that display that trait gender
differences arise in a similar fashion
Darwin added as quote the strongest and
most vigorous men have been able to
select the more attractive women and
together they would have succeeded in
rearing the greater average number of
offspring thanks to sexual selection
Darwin concluded men possess greater
strength and intellect while women
display more beauty and tenderness
nature made it so well here was an
argument rooted in its time in place
Victorian England the scent of man
offered the first comprehensive
naturalistic theory of human evolution
but it didn't change many minds
Europeans and Americans had hotly
debated the proposition that humans
evolved from beasts ever since the
publication of Origin of Species in 1859
but most can continue to reject the
ideal long after the appearance of the
scent of man in 1871 including many
evolutionists within darwin's inner
circle for example Alfred Russel Wallace
who codiscovered the theory of evolution
by natural selection along with Darwin
and who remained a staunch darwinists on
other matters became persuaded that what
he called a overruling intelligence
created the first humans by ennobling
anthro poedel apes with enlightened
Minds quote natural selection could only
have endowed the savage with a bank
brain a little superior to that of an
ape Wallace wrote in 1869 and maintained
ever after whereas he actually possesses
one very little inferior to that of the
average members of our learning
societies Darwin's mentor and friend
geologist Charles Lyell promptly
endorsed Wallace's position much to
Darwin's display he called them both
traitors for his part asa gray
steadfastly maintained that God
supervised the beneficial variations
that produced humankind well Darwin's
view of human origins receive
even less support from non-scientists
the triumph of evolutionism within the
victorian scientific community during
the 1860s did not translate into
widespread popular acceptance of the
theory especially with respect to human
origins science did not then dominate
how europeans and americans viewed the
natural world much less the supernatural
world the matter of human origins was
particularly sensitive because it
impacted how people viewed themselves
other persons and god crucially
evolutionary naturalism undermined
belief in an indwelling spiritual as
opposed to material soul which many
people dafont defined as the very
essence of humaneness the doctrine that
God specially created the first people
by giving them eternal non-material
souls carried with it certain
implications about the meaning of human
life the theory that humans evolved by
purely naturalistic means from soulless
animals carried others and many
individuals found it difficult to switch
and 1871 cartoon in the British magazine
punch captured the tension note 1871 the
very the very year this was actually
written as an editorial cartoon response
to dissent of man as published us came
out and punch right when that magazine
came out right in that book came up this
cartoon showed an earnest young husband
reading to his wife there Neal he's
kneeled in front of a fireplace very
home-like scene and reading to his wife
and his infant child from Darwin's just
published the scent of man you can read
the title of the book in the cartoon and
here's what the caption caption says
it's the man talking first so you see
Mary baby is descended from a hairy
quadra pet with pointed ears and a tail
we all are he explained his wife
countered speak for yourself jack I'm
not descended from anything of the kind
i beg to say and baby takes after me
this captured the general mood late in
his life Darwin could claim excuse me
late in his life Wallace could claim
with some hyperbola that quote all of
the greatest writers and thinkers agreed
that the higher mental and spiritual
nature of man is not the mirror animal
nature advance through survival of the
fittest novelist Leo Tolstoy proclaimed
this view in Russia for example and the
prominent congregational cleric Henry
war Harry ward beecher did so in the
united states both embraced evolutionism
to a point but maintained that only God
could make a soul Roman Catholic Church
doctrine fitfully gravitated toward
accepting a similar position during the
late 1890s or excuse me during the 1880s
1890's late in the 1800s British Prime
Minister William Gladstone made a point
of endorsing the divine creation of
humankind or at least the human soul
whether expressed in scientific
commentary or editorial cartoons the
basic sentiment was similar most people
simply refuse to believe that their
highly developed minds morals or
emotions evolved from those of beasts
the gap appeared to great they felt
themselves superior to other animals for
many of these feelings carried more
weight than any abstract scientific
theory those sentiments were captured in
a 1872 editorial calm cartoon appearing
in a chic London literary journal soon
after publication of Darwin's to
principal books on human evolution in
1871 he published a sin of man and then
followed it a year later with an equally
powerful exposition of the theory of
human of that humans had evolved a book
called expressions of emotions in man
and animals the cartoon I mean talking
about featured a stylish woman scolding
a tailed AP she looking Darwin quote
really mr. Darwin say what you like
about the descent of men but I wish you
would leave my emotions alone just as
some people instinctively rejected the
idea of human evolution others embraced
it for reasons that had little to do
with science
materialists atheists and radical
secularist had long displayed a certain
fondness for evolutionary theories of
origin such as those of the French
enlightenment naturalist Lamarck
anything for these people anything to
dispense with God even though Darwin
held strictly conventional political and
economic views his theory attracted the
usual crowd Huxley and the influential
german biologist Ernst Haeckel initially
embraced Darwinism in part because it
supported their anti-clerical agendas
for science and society Karl Marx sahrin
Darwinism as scientific basis for his
vision of the class struggle in 1873 he
sent Darwin a copy of Das Kapital
inscribed quot mr. Charles Darwin on the
part of his sincere admirer Karl Marx
and avowed capitalists darwin
acknowledged the gift cordially but
never opened it to this day the book
remains in Darwin's library with the
pages uncut in the United States
feminist leader Elizabeth Cady Stanton
welcome Darwinism as a means to
undermine what she saw as biblically
based arguments for the subordination of
women quote the real difficulty in
woman's case is that the whole
foundation of the Christian religion
rests on her temptation and man's fall
she wrote in the woman's bible if
however we accept the Darwinian theory
that the race has been a gradual growth
from the lower to the higher form of
life and the story of the fall is a myth
well we can exonerate the snake
emancipate the woman and reconstruct a
more rational religion for the 19th
century from the right wing those are
from the left wing of the political
spectrum from the right wing of the
political spectrum you get a similar
account at least from the secular right
wing of the spectrum the enormously
influential 19th century English social
philosopher Herbert Spencer already an
avowed evolutionist even before Darwin
published any of his works
freely worked Darwinian materialism into
his progressive estas ophy of social
development which was dubbed social
Darwinism by his critics heykal carried
these ideas to the german-speaking world
with translated editions of Hegel's most
popular book returning back to Britain
and the United States to reinforce
social Darwinism in its homeland as
social theorists Spencer Hagel and
Darwin became inexorably linked in the
public mind during the late 19th century
Spencer's many followers whose numbers
comprised a virtual social registry of
the anglo-american money delete
typically embraced Darwinism as well in
his autobiography for example Scottish
American industrialist Andrew Carnegie
recalled the day in 1870s when his
reading of Darwin's descent of man
heckles history of creation and various
books by Spencer transformed his life
quote I remember that light came in I
remember that light came in a flood and
all was clear not only had had got rid
of theology and the supernatural but I
had found the truth of evolution he
wrote man was not created with an
instinct for his own degradation but
from the lower he had risen to the
higher form that's Andrew Carnegie for
people like Carnegie Darwinism became a
religion or an alternative to religion
pictorially this sentiment appeared in a
popular 1883 poster attributed to the
London secularist George holyoke which
purported to illustrate the
fragmentation of the established British
national church into various factions
raising ranging from high Church
anglicanism and Roman Catholicism to
dissent and rationalism in the upper
left corner under the banner Darwinism
an ape leads Spencer Huxley and other
agnostics away from the central
umbrella-like Dome of London saint paul
cathedral toward a distant cloud labeled
protoplasm
a bust of Darwin arises above the cloud
with his great white beer Darwin could
as readily appear godlike as a fish and
during the late 19th century
illustrators pictured in both ways it
had less to do with science than with
society well in some ways little has
changed in the past century many
otherwise committed evolutionists draw
the line on materialism when it comes to
the ascent of man for example the noted
Oxford University ornithologist David
lack whose groundbreaking 1947 study of
Darwin's finches on the Galapagos
Islands gave wing to the modern
neo-darwinian synthesis nevertheless set
of the higher attributes of humans quote
science has not accounted for morality
truth beauty individual responsibility
or self-awareness and many people hold
that from its nature it can never do so
unquote similarly the noted American
geneticist Francis Collins who has
directed the Human Genome Project since
the 1990s wrote in 2002 quote science
will certainly not shed any light on
what it means to love someone what it
means to have a spiritual dimension to
our existence nor will it tell us much
about the character of God in quote
opinion survey suggests that Colin
speaks for about forty percent of the
american people and up to a like
percentage of American scientists twenty
posits God is somehow involved in the
evolutionary process at least to the
extent of breathing a supernaturally
created soul into a naturally evolved
body for the record the Roman Catholic
Church approves of this position quote
rather than the theory of evolution we
should speak of several theories of
evolution materialistic reductionist and
spiritualist Pope John Paul the second
declared in a 1996 message of the
Pontifical Pontifical Academy of
Sciences the one that got all the press
about the Pope endorsing evolution this
is what he actually said he goes on to
say quote theories of evolution which in
accordance with the philosophies inspire
them inspiring them can
the mind is emerging from the forces of
living matter or as a mere epiphenomenon
of this matter are incompatible with the
truth about man in some way this
statements echoes the speculation of the
Jesuit scientist Pierre feel hard the
Chardin in the 1950s which attracted
considerable attention about a half
century ago and the thoughts of a long
line of mainline and even conservative
Protestant theologians over the past
century these percentages mask a
fundamental split between science and
society however while roughly a similar
share of both the public general public
and the scientific community admit to at
least some element of theism into their
thinking on human evolution about
neither case about four and ten their
other halves or more precisely there are
other six-tenths differ sharply among
the American people on average about
five out of the remaining six
fundamentally reject the concept that
humans evolved from lower animals while
by alike margins most American
scientists dismiss any role for God and
evolution even in the descent of man
like Darwin many of them see human
mental and moral attributes including
altruistic behavior and belief in God as
the product of natural forces or as
British science writer Richard Dawkins
likes to put it a blind watchmaker
Dawkins books have become bestsellers in
the United States and his vision of
human evolution or more precisely the
vision that he has popularized from the
work of such preeminent late 20th
century biologists as William Hamilton
and EO wilson is shared by many
evolutionary biologists today humans
like all living organisms are survival
machines robot vehicles blindly
programmed to preserve the selfish
molecules known as genes Dawkins writes
the genes themselves cannot plan ahead
or respond to their environment he
stresses they simply reproduce
themselves with occasional random
mutations that may or may not assist
their survival and we are the
astonishing or should I say astonished
result
Dawkins finds this view of life
exhilarating for him it frees humans
from the burden of purposeful design in
nature which he identifies as quote the
most influential of the arguments for
the existence of God unlike the
controlling purposes of a designing God
Dawkins exalts natural selection the
blind unconscious automatic processes
which Darwin described in which we now
know is the explanation for existence
and apparently purposeful form of life
has no purpose in mind end quote well
from their very outset what people found
most auxiliary auxiliary most exciting
most titillating or most frightening it
depended on the person about Darwinism
was the prospect that humans evolved
from beasts by a naturalistic process
that went back in some material cause
and effect chained to the earliest form
of life Dawkins now expresses that view
in starkly dogmatic terms but except for
the bit about genes which were unknown
in the 19th century he does not claim to
say anything more than Darwin said in
dissent of man or for that matter in
origin of species I opened my talk
tonight by quoting from Adam Sedgwick's
wistful 1859 response to Darwin on the
origins book although Sedgwick closed
his letter the one I began with with a
light-hearted reference to himself as
quote a son of a monkey neither in that
letter nor and his other voluminous
writings did he ever give one inch on a
divine source for the human soul this
was fundamental to Sedgwick's faith and
to his science for him and most other
Victorians as for so many today
including any number of evolutionists
that was and is no laughing matter the
human soul remains at the heart of the
ongoing debate over origins well there
it goes that's that's collected from
different places within the book and I
hope that worked rather than a strict
reading I'd like to open the floor for
some questions if people have some
questions about the overall book again
the book doesn't
just talk about human evolution it's and
if this doesn't talk about the soul it's
a it's a history of the theory of
evolution and I opened any questions
people might have yes other people after
this light he found this light what a
few people is but actually view much
like he before he got this light truly
Andrew Carnegie um well Andrew Carnegie
became a deep believer in evolution and
and he also began a viewer in what we
believe her and what we call social
Darwinism now people at the at the
bottom end of the rung what he'd you as
the bottom into the rug sort of saw that
called him a robber baron or he's a sort
of a robber baron type character but
people at the other end view them is a
tremendous philanthropist is a
tremendous innovator as a tremendous
capitalist who pushed our country
forward and it depends a little bit on
one's view of evolution I mean you
notice Carnegie logically from this sort
of you would open libraries all across
the country why because he didn't want
he wanted a meritocracy he wanted the
best he did many of these people like
Carnegie many of these people in
Darwin's day and it wasn't limited to
just just Carnegie I mean it would
involve Darwin himself Darwin thought
this way Darwin was a member of a
capitalist family part of the rising
British class that was pushing out the
established elite the ones that were
born landed the landed aristocracy and
this rising money gentry well this was
the group that was very open the idea of
evolution the idea of change and that
change is progress the change goes
forward and we advance and Carnegie
viewed himself that way he moved over
from Scotland and became wealthy in
America and tried to help others who
were you know were gifted through
libraries and other means to advance but
he also realized that that you know that
there and we wouldn't quite say double
take the hindmost but but he's too I
guess it was too secular of you to use
that phrase but you know there's there's
people who aren't moving ahead and the
the whole social
when his views that providing social
services for these people Herbert
Spencer would argue was detrimental
because you're putting a dead weight on
the progress the evolution the progress
of humanity forward just as they viewed
establish aristocracies as as dead
weight they wanted this new rising class
to it to move forward and Carnegie
Carnegie reflected that view as did many
people now this was also the era that
shortly after Carnegie eugenics begins
developing which was the which was the
more rather than sort of we don't want
to formatively kill people or let them
die in the streets but rather will the
lower groups the less efficient we'll
just sterilize so that they don't
reproduce and therefore we can continue
to take care of them nicely we can
provide welfare the concern for people
like a Carnegie and people like Spencer
about welfare was that welfare would
would keep too many people alive and you
need the survival of the soul survival
fittest process to weed out the weak and
so Carnegie would have you'd that he
would have viewed for progress he would
want things like libraries you want to
push society forward it's captured in
his autobiography or other readings and
that's the sort of social impact that I
tried to follow in the book and I
provide a lot more of course about
people like Carnegie or Rockefeller in
the book in the way it fits when the
social Darwin question question over
here well many hundreds of years
literature seems to confirm that human
nature has remained the same particular
regard to relationships between people
do theorists that believe in evolution
except the static nature of human nature
or do they see some trend line that's
going forward in other words is the
evolutionary process come to an end or
is it continuing in some way and what
are their projections for the end of the
trend line that's a wonderful question
because that's an issue that it's not
just a question people had today
that's one of the themes that reappear I
could have put to get pull together
parts from the book to follow that
because people did wonder how does this
apply to human society not just the
evolution of humans from from primates
of some sort but what about the
evolution of culture and a lot of people
accepted evolution even before Darwin's
work came out though Darwin gave it a
stronger scientific basis people like
Herbert Spencer who I mentioned who was
an evolutionist before actually a
Lamarckian form of evolution before he
before Darwin's work was published
because they saw social evolution going
on cultural evolution going on during
human history and that somehow we're
human society is now more advanced than
it was in the times of the
hunter-gatherer societies or the time of
the Romans or the time middle ages and
that's why it sort of fits its day and
time because if you're living in mid
19th century England you can feel
progress around you because new industry
new technology urbanization things are
changing if you are sitting in in 16th
century England you wouldn't feel quite
that same dynamism and that's a part of
the way that evolution is a scientific
idea fits its time in place but on the
other hand you're absolutely right they
look back and they say well you know we
don't have any writers as good as
Shakespeare we don't really have any
writers as good as maybe Cicero or Meiko
or Ovid or some of the Romans of the
Greeks how much are we really really
progressing well then you then some
people will see a lot of social
evolution with industrialization it
depends on what you're focusing on other
people would say way this is going a lot
slower than we think well either way it
sort of works it depends on how you take
the approach and that gets debated back
and forth because once Darwin comes out
with his idea he has a lot of evidence
about animals and plants the Origin
species is a wonderful book with packed
with scientific it's a wonderful
plumbing very persuasive
shifts all this evidence revolution but
he doesn't have any evidence in there at
all about human evolution and that leads
people to come up with the idea while
humans are special everything else
evolved but humans were separately
created which later became for those of
you read my scopes trial book that was
of course william jennings bryan s
position everything else evolved but
humans were separately created Adam and
Eve was plopped down after eons of
evolution and other people took that as
as and out and to counter that people
like Huxley and people like Lyle even
would look would try to posit that
there's been an awful lot of social
evolution and the social evolution from
primitive savage to advanced English
people or they were course it was Hegel
and Germany was advanced german people
at dependent where they were who were
the advanced people was usually
themselves people quite like themselves
actually were the most advanced and they
would show this social evolution but
when it when as time get up went on and
we didn't get a lot of evidence he
actually thought that evolution would
remain a theory until they saw one
species evolved from another species
sort of complex species and he figured
that come out in his lifetime with with
focused breeding experiments but when it
didn't happen people sort keep looking
back and saying well the process just
takes longer than we thought precious
just takes longer to evolve completely
different things and then the idea that
humans haven't changed very much that
there could have been a Shakespeare four
hundred years ago and there could have
been a homer I don't know 3,000 years
ago ever long it was there could have
been the theories of Buddha or you know
the ideas of Confucius that long ago he
just shows that humans take a long time
just like everything else that evolution
is a slow slow process when it comes to
to highly evolved species and so you can
use that would explain why there could
be such advanced people so far back but
nonetheless almost inevitably people who
believe in evolution believe that human
evolution if if we don't destroy
ourselves in the process will continue
on and that people will continue to
evolve and there will be more the
percentage of advanced people will be
greater and that the human body will
evolve and the human mind will evolve
and you can read many evolutionists
today or as I talked about in the book
way back in time of Darwin or time of of
Lamarck before that who are speculating
about how humans would change and you
know is probably captured in that
popular song you know in the year 24 24
you know man is evolved and you each get
them into more this mindless brain there
is constantly this undercurrent and
evolutionary thought of speculating of
what humanity is going to become like
because all these so many of the people
in it who deal with evolution no matter
what they're dealing with plants or
fruit flies now there when you when you
read there which I've had the
opportunity to do read their private
notes read their private letters read
what they're talking about not what
they're writing in their formal
scientific documents I was able to get
in and read those things they're almost
invariably to talking about people and
what does this mean for us so that was
sort of a fun aspect of it another
question drawing in essence of parallel
in evolution between organic and
inorganic systems because the evolution
of physics only became significant in
recent years because we were able to
model analytically not stick with
empirical approaches that you currently
do with biology and if you can model
analytically a functional behavior of
the genes you certainly should be able
to predict and so it would condense the
system so you can evaluate it in
appropriate time space certainly one of
the exciting aspects of evolution today
is at the molecular level thanks to the
discovery of DNA and the better
understanding of DNA and and once you're
dealing with this is obviously tightly
connected with chemistry with organic
and inorganic chemistry and then
therefore with physics and that sort of
modeling is one of the truly exciting
areas of evolution and and which I could
deal with in the later chapters
book as that area of evidence because
when you look through the history of
evolution and the there were lots of
main areas of sport but if you go back
in the in the in the late 1800s it was
paleontology was fossils all throughout
that that century actually throughout
the entire 19th century it was
paleontology and then comparative
morphology the fact that structures of
like whales have the five life of five
fingers and bats do which wouldn't
wouldn't make any sense if there wasn't
a connection or the most famous bit of
fossils ties the morphology together
that discoveries of cope and the other
the other paleontologists that the
horses which have a single hoof now
trace back to five hoofed horse and 55
toad horse then three then four then
three then two and then the single hoof
which shows this putting this was the
evidence that persuaded virtually the
entire scientific community to quickly
accept evolution we didn't explain how
it happened then you come to the early
nineteen first half of the 20th century
its genetics and its theoretical
genetics and they discovered all this
evidence these connections from studying
the the classical genesis the pattern of
genetics and the classical has worked
out by Thomas Hunt Morgan of Mendelian
genetics so perfectly fit an
evolutionary theory but then you move up
with watson and crick in the discovery
of the double helix and then the working
out of the of the DNA structure how
wonderfully that fits with a theory of
evolution and now that is probably
replace paleontology and replace
comparative morphology as the most
interesting most studied area of
scientific support for evolution so we
really have a wonderful long history and
it more than any of the other areas fits
evolution organic evolution biological
evolution more neatly as you express
into the other sciences like physics and
into the evolution of of in argant in
organic evolution chemical evolution and
then the evolution of the whole
all the whole universe that's an
exciting aspect of evolutionary studies
that is going on right now and you're
right that's very recent and it's
pushing the foot pushing forward
evolutionary theory someone had
analytically modeled the e.coli saw the
functional behavior of the genes as if
you eliminate and add gene structure so
we're getting into something tangible so
that you don't have to find yourself
that you have to wait centuries to
discover how what evolution does you can
do it in analytical form can model it
into a persuasive area and that's why
when I check me the scientists are
convinced to the theory ever more so
because of that sort of work in your
right as i said in the opening there's
no place where more exciting work in
this field is being done in the entire
world there are other places or places
in australia their places in England
there other places in the United States
but nowhere is more exciting than right
here in this town UCSD had a question
way over there I don't know if we can
reach over there but what's right
conceptual predecessor of Darwin Darwin
being born when the mark was about 50 do
you have any ideas about how Lamarck on
his inspiration or any intellectual
predecessors of the mark yeah you asked
about Lamar canned I do di don't start
this Darwin doesn't appear to about a
third of the way through the book are
quarter the way through the book
Lamarque Lamarck had developed in France
a really the first fully fleshed out
scientific theory of evolution people
had been but his inspiration came out of
the or at least the way I piece it
together from the best i can do of my
reading of Lamar and his evidence is
that the theory of evolution had the
idea of organic evolution let me call
that I won't call it a theory the idea
of organic evolution had had appeared
during the French enlightenment
beginning pretty pretty strongly maybe
eight seventeen fifty or so eater oh ho
back boof all had talked about it and
they came about it in the usual fashion
because you can find people theorizing
about discussing it's never reached the
level of a theory way back to the Greeks
Greek scientists or Greek natural
philosophers and you know when you think
about it species have to be created or
as Aristotle said always existed that
was his way out of the problem or or had
come from other species and where else
could they have come from and so these
ideas had had been discussed in Greeks
time and always had remained sort of
very much in the background but then
they had popped forward in France before
Lamarck and Lamarck was a was very
different than Darwin he was a born
radical he was he was like Alfred Russel
Wallace it was also a born radical that
you know the Tom Paine sort who will
naturally gravitate to a radical idea to
a secular idea to a materialistic idea
to a revolutionary idea and evolution
was all of those things it upset the
natural order and he was a person who
would want to upset the natural order
now the theory worked out was was really
quite different than Darwinism he
posited that the things spontaneously
generated and then they everything that
spontaneously generated just evolved for
it is like getting on an escalator and
everything about learning why there are
different sorts of things complex things
and simple things and is they've just
evolved for a shorter or longer period
of time everything is moving up this
escalator adapting to the environment
like the giraffe stretching his neck but
there and so they're all going in
slightly different directions but
they're growing in Crete there's an
increasing complexity in life you know
organic material inorganic material just
naturally assembles and as it is some
sort of a naturalistic process and then
has an internal material soul not a
supernatural soul in it that advances it
forward like an escalator always rising
up now that's very different than
Darwinism where you could just have like
one or so beginning things and then it's
a tree of life that
branches out in different directions
it's a very different concept of
evolution but it was fully worked out
and Darwin knew about it as did others
it was highly criticized but yet it had
its continued supporters it rigged and
it was and as the idea that of evolution
had gained force in the early 1800s and
been picked up by people like Herbert
Spencer the only theory they had to go
to isla mark and so the market Lamarque
ism had continued and was actually
growing in force in the 1880s 1840s and
1850s what Darwin was trying to do
privately after he became an
evolutionist he couldn't buy because he
wasn't radical by his nature he was very
very to say the term conservative it'd
be more he was very Orthodox in his
social cultural political views economic
views and he didn't want this he didn't
want a French Revolution like Lamarck
sort of like he wanted a he and what
that sort of thing he wanted the
meritocracy and he wanted to scrap more
gradual sort of evolution so he spent
his time trying to think once he
converted to evolutionism he says
there's got it it can't be like a mark
is doing it and so he spent his time
trying to come up with an alternative
theory and he hit upon natural selection
now Wallace who was very radical was
also adopted evolutionary idea
instinctively but then hit upon the same
theory and the rest as they say is
history question no question genetic
research and engineering will this take
evolution out of science and into the
realm of history you in what and what we
do as we go into genetics and the
manipulation of genes doing oh I see all
right I see what you're saying will we
will it's not that it'll take evolution
out of the role of of you take natural
evolutionary process will be taken would
become just history because people will
be running the evolutionary process
themselves
and so manipulating things but depending
on how you look at it even if that
happened that's still evolution it's
it's so it's not taking evolution and
putting it in history what it is it's
taking evolution and putting at UCSD and
UCSD and it's spin-off companies will be
will be helping to lead us forward or in
other countries maybe the government now
this this isn't necessarily new if I was
here a hundred years ago talking right
here probably we would have been you
have been asking the same question but
it would have been about eugenics they
thought that the same thing would happen
eugenics they were very confident a
hundred years ago that eugenics worked
and that is selective breeding of people
because already they were doing
selective breeding of animals a big
proponent of eugenics was right near
here well little north of here Luther
Burbank who was famous for producing all
sorts of new plants and he wanted to it
with people too and of course California
had you know a model eugenics law and
more people of course it's famous got
more people were sterilized sexually
sterilized in California than in any
other state in the Union people were
picked out of the asylums and the
institutions for the mentally [ __ ]
for sterilization here it's a it's a
grand story I tell it a little bit in
this book it's appeared in I had another
book just on eugenics and there are
other people who write about it it's a
pretty well-known story those so people
100 years ago would have thought the
same thing and you can read people a
hundred years ago you can read them in
my book if you want people who were
saying a hundred years ago we're taking
over the evolution process of evolution
and we're going to operate it well the
reason why I give you this bit of
history in it because I'm a historian
you ask the question to historian if
you'd asked this to a futurologist you
would have gotten a different answer but
you asked historian and my answer that
is it's somewhat similar thing will
happen has happened with eugenics that
is that the promise and the hope yeah
they'll be is in some ways different
than the reality that will play out and
certainly we do we did a lot of crop
breeding Lister I enjoy Luther Burbank
products in my garden too
this day of course and there will be
those things but still nature will take
its course in lots of things as well and
so it'll be a give-and-take interaction
between humans influencing process just
as th Huxley dreamed about now he was
New Genesis but he also talked that
humans can take over then his grandson
julian huxley used to write about it at
the middle of the 1950's if some of you
remember Julian Huxley's work in the 50s
and 60s very popular writer about how
humans can guide evolution humans will
become interactive in the process but if
you think about it we've always been
interacted with the process we have been
choosing which breeds of cattle survive
the cattle that walk around here in
California aren't anything like native
cattle and there are lots of those
kettles and the Hogs that we we eat for
pork aren't anything like wild hogs so
we've been involved and that's been
happening ever since the Polynesians in
the ancient and the people living in the
Tigris and Euphrates valley started
picking out crops the corn we when the
when the Native Americans were picking
out that those sort of things we've been
in humans have been interplay with our
environment for as long as we we may
enter play more but nature will still be
involved too so I think it will continue
on it will be nature but it'll also be
humans you mentioned that we pick our
mates but we want to pick our children
we want we really want to go
intelligence or environmental stress or
health issues I in the days of eugenics
you can read the accounts of a hundred
years ago and these these heads of the
american medical association or heads of
the rockefeller foundation or whatever
carnegie foundation we're talking about
we're going to create people with
perfect bodies and perfect minds and
this is going to be our vehicle because
we're going to we're going to be able to
use proper mating techniques and
breeding techniques of humans and you
know it people do it people but people
have always picked spouses based on
whether they think their children what
what sort of offspring they'll produce
that's how people have always picked
their their mates are some people who
pick their a
that's what Darwin thought the
Hottentots pick their mates he was
intentionally picking what he would
dazeem as a savage group and so they
said they even they do it so of course
we do it Darwin was very careful and he
picked for a mate on who would be a who
would produce good offspring and he
picked well Emma was a wonderful wife
for him wonderful woman the so people
have always been doing it will we be
doing with more force and with more
power as some will and that power will
grow i think that you know i think it's
it's of concern how it might be used
certainly if government tried to do it
look when the look when the when we did
eugenics sort of happenstance in america
was one thing but when hitler took
control of eugenics it was quite another
thing the results and i could see a
government using this power in a in a in
a frightful manner in a frightfully
inhuman manner so with any science
there's always concerns there's always
miss uses but you know the truth is you
can never put the genie back in the
bottle and as long as this powers
available people will use it and we just
have to figure out how we can do the
best and that's one reason why in this
book in the history of evolution i use a
whole chapter on eugenics and I talk a
lot about social Darwinism because these
are important questions and I want to
give people a historical basis I'm not
trying to downplay them I want to hit
the issues just why I talked about the
human soul it we've been easier to talk
about fossils today but what's really
interesting is how it affects to how
people think about the human soul that's
one area or what you're talking about
those are the those are the important
issues and I want this book to be a
vehicle so people can get into these
issues and not to skirt them and to
avoid them from the discussion and the
questions dr. Larson I think the
remarkable part of your title is no
hyperbole we're going to take one more
question and then we'll you'll have time
I hope to stay after and sign some
copies of the book and we have books
available as well so one more question
right here in the front thank you
how serious do you think is the current
attack on public education especially in
the Bible Belt I make troops back there
doing some research on a project and the
relatives all over the bible belt and it
seems to me extremely very vigorous
aggressive attack on public on public
schools over the teaching of science I
don't I don't and I don't think the
attack is only I'm broadening your
question I don't think the attack is
only over the theory of evolution I'm a
product of public education myself I
went through through first grade through
high school in a public school I went to
graduate school at a public university
went to part of my college at a public
university I'm a great believer in
public education and I do think that
public education is under tremendous
stress in America today and it's not
just because of the theory of evolution
theory of evolution is one of the
vehicles and it's and it's concerning I
think that the the budget crunches are
hurting public education I don't think
teachers are paid public school teachers
a good public school teacher I don't
know of anybody more valuable to our
society than a good public school
teacher but if the pay is not good
enough will you get a lot of public
school teachers who aren't all that good
but also people don't go into that field
and they're a treasure and one of the
vehicles that has been used you is it
along with others is that the issues
about the teaching of the theory of
evolution and that some people should
should not go to public schools and
instead should be homeschooled or
instead should go to christian academy's
or go to private schools I think there's
probably a place for homeschooling
there's probably a place there's
certainly a place for private schools
but we've got to keep our cub League
schools strong and if this is being used
to undermine support for the public
schools or is used in a divisive way I
think that I firmly believe that
students need to understand whatever
their views are they need to understand
the theory of evolution because it's one
of the powerful theories of our day it
affects even
if you don't believe in the technically
in the scientific theory of evolution
you still these same people believe in
cultural social evolution they they they
see society evolving evolution creeps
into the way they think about so many
things they think about change they
think about progress and if you if you
try to sense central to all that theory
is the theory scientific theory of
evolution even whether or not you accept
that you should you should learn it in
schools and when people try to take it
out of schools they're doing it I
believe a tremendous disservice to their
own children and two other children's
who need to need to understand this
theory to deal with with life today
that's one of the dangers of I think one
of the drawbacks when you go if you go
to a school and you don't get this
theory you should get it should be
included in public schools everyone
should support it if people and that's
what I'm hoping that Anna part or all
for my book is that it sort of evolved
out of the lectures and the talks I've
given on the Scopes trial which I
because because that book got a lot of
attention I've been speak a lot on and I
find that so many people critics of
evolution don't understand the theory of
evolution but even supporters of
evolution even people who support
evolution in one at Titan schools really
don't understand what a rich and diverse
and complex they just have some idea of
like Darwin and the finches and not all
these aspects and all this intricacies
and all the controversies with in
evolution and if you see it in all its
richness and all its controversies and
watch it develop and watch the different
theories I think then that should be a
more you know another way to learn
evolution and i hope the book works
toward that process because it's not a
theory without controversy it's a theory
with controversies but that's part of
learning about it and I hope the book in
a minor way contributes to that but in a
major way people stand up and make sure
that that that the public schools are
supported and public schools include on
the theory of evolution within biology
because i think it's central to it and
most places
it is there but it's a controversy that
continues to to dog is politicize it
it's politicized it's I think it's used
by people who have another other maybe
other agendas to advance use it for
fundraising purposes and it can be very
divisive so I hope that people will will
will will put that to one side and
realize the importance of getting this
theory taught well taught in its full
richness not in a stereotyped away not
in a strawman way but in its full
richness in our public schools so thank
you for the question Edward Larson is
author of summer for the gods which are
in the 1998 pulitzer prize for history
his latest evolution is published by
modern library an imprint of Random
House and